In a world where clocks abound,
we constantly ask, "what time is it?"
but rarely do we stop consider, "what is time?"
In the July 25th Science News,
our staff writers tackle this question.
They take a look at time from three
completely different perspectives: body
brain and universe. When it comes to the
body's clock biologists ponder time from
the perspective of evolutionary history.
They want to know how and why life-forms
acquire internal clocks that guide
everyday life. Molecular biology writer
Tina Hesman Saey explores the circadian
clocks built into nearly every one of
our cells and how they relate to the
most primitive clocks found in archaea
and algae. Our brains take on time is a
separate story. Neuroscience writer Laura
Sanders explores how the clocks in our
heads help us make sense of the world
and what makes our perception time
appear to change as a consequence of our
experiences. There are even some hints
about how faulty timekeeping in the
brain can factor into disorders such as
schizophrenia.
Perhaps the most brain boggling
exploration time comes from physics
writer Andrew Grant. he grapples with
time in terms of grab and the grandeur
of the universe
why does time always run forward even
though the laws of physics should permit its tick
backward? A new simulation points to
gravity and suggest that the force may
allow the universe to have one past: the
big bang, and two futures.
You can read about these explorations of time and more
at www.sciencenews.org/time.